Sharpe ratio is a metric that
adjusts return for risk.
And it enables us in a quantitative way
to asses each of these
example compared portfolios.
So Sharpe ratio will show us for
instance, that in this case ABC is
better because It has about the same
volatility as XYZ, but higher return.
If it were to assess these two, even
though they both have the same return,
it'll say XYZ is better
because it's got lower risk.
And finally, in this case where these
two are very close and it's hard for
us as humans to determine which
one is better, Sharpe ratio here
will give us a number that will
help us determine between the two.
So with regard to the numbers that
Sharpe ratio ends up providing us,
all else being equal, lower risk is
better, higher return is better.
Sharpe ratio also considers something
called the risk free rate of return.
That's the interest rate you would get
on your money if you put it in a risk
free asset like a bank account or
a short term treasury.
The reason that it includes this number,
is we always need to consider,
gee, maybe this asset we've got
isn't performing as well as the return I
would get it I just put it in the bank.
Now, lately, as of mid-2015,
the risk free rate of
return is about zero.
In other words, if you were to put
your money in the bank or to buy
very short term treasury bonds, that's
the interest rate they would pay you.
And this is why lately folks have put so
much money into the stock market,
because you can't make money putting
your money in the bank these days.
The Sharpe ratio is named for
William Sharpe.
And he developed something called
the Sharpe ratio that accounts for
all of these.
Now think about what the form of
that equation would look like.